Are there ever situations where you should hold your tongue and not speak what
you believe?
Yeah.
You,
most of the time,
look,
it's really a tricky thing to figure out when to say what you have to say.
But I can give you a couple of rules of thumb.
It's a general question name and I can't list all the situations,
but I can give you some strategic advice.
So for example,
if someone is,
um,
has said rude things to you,
for example,
says a rude thing to you,
maybe you shouldn't respond immediately even though you're very irritated
because maybe that's just an impulsive response and one that you'll regret when
you make an anger that you'll regret.
And so I would say when you're dealing with someone and you want to chastise
them,
then you should wait for them to cin three times,
right?
So the first time they're rude to you think,
oh,
well they're probably having a bad day,
or I misunderstood,
or I'm,
I'm rude sometimes too.
And you know,
I'll just let it go.
But you don't forget and you don't pretend it didn't happen.
And then it happens again.
And you think,
okay,
well that could still be fluke.
That could still be
okay.
That could still be situational.
So maybe I'll just hold my damn tongue,
but I'll remember that.
I'll remember.
And then the third time they do it,
then you think,
no,
no three times.
That's a pattern.
And so then you can go to them and you can say,
look,
this happened.
And then maybe they did die and you say,
well yeah,
you can deny it,
but then this happened and maybe they denied and you can say why you can deny
that.
But then this happened.
Okay.
And you know,
three times the charm and that's a time when you should stand up for yourself
and say what you have to say.
Look,
you have to put yourself in a position where you can say what you have to say.
You have to think it through,
you have to have a plan.
And you can't just launch yourself off the edge of a cliff and hope that God's
going to catch you on the way down.
And I'm saying,
you know,
it's definitely the case that if you have something to say,
like if you're being oppressed at work,
if you've got some,
you know,
horrible tyrant as a boss,
or maybe that's happening to you in your marriage,
or maybe you're the horrible tyrant,
God only knows.
There's things that have to be said.
But that doesn't mean you can just blurt them out.
You have to have a plan.
You have to figure out what you want to say.
You have to make it as minimally troublesome as possible.
You have to have the goal that you want in mind,
and you have to have a backup plan like this,
the sort of thing that you're talking about.
You know where you need to say something that's like a little war.
You don't want to walk into that unarmed and unprepared.
Now,
that doesn't mean that you should,
that means that you should set up your life so that you're firmly enough
anchored in a variety of different ways so that you can say what you need to say
without dying as a consequence.
So.